طب في سؤال تقني لو سمحت نعلم انه جل
المعطيات يعني اذا صح هذا التفسير التي
يتم نقلها على الانترنت يتم تخزينها
بتبدا او تنتهي في خوادم داخلي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انا يعني هذا انه في
النهايه هناك حكومه يمكنها عرقله سيطره
على هذه الصناعه
هذا مؤكد هناك مفهوم جديد يطلق عليه توطين
البيانات اي بمعنى تاميمها وجعلها بمثابه
القطاع الذي لا يقل اهميه عن الجيش
والغذاء حيث تنظر والكثير من الدول في
كيفيه تحديد البيانات التي يمكن ان تغادر
وما نوع البيانات التي تنبغي معالجتها
داخلها وما البيانات التي لا ينبغي ان
تخرج من حدودها مثل بيانات مواطنيها
الماليه بل وحتى بعد البيانات المتعلقه
باعمالهم اليوميه واسلوب عيشهم فهي مهمه
جدا وينبغي للحكومات ان تحتفظ بها داخل
دولها
عاده كيف بيتم تنظيم قطاع الانترنت
وتعديله
البيانات هي النفط الجديد ما تمثله ربما
حتى يفوق التغييرات العميقه التي شهدها
العالم في اواخر القرن التاسع عشر وعلى كل
دوله ان تعالجها على اعتبار انها قطاع
حيوي لا يقبل المقايده او التقليل منه
وعليها ان تتعرف على برامج الشركات والدول
المختلفه في التعامل مع بيانات مواطنيها
للاعتبار منها وبناء مناهجها حولها اعتقد
انه حان الوقت لحكومه العالم للانخراط في
البيانات وتحديد نوع البيانات التي يمكن
اجازه خروجها والاخرى التي لا ينبغي لها
تجاوز مياهها الاقليميه
لو سالنا كيف يمكن للكبلات البحريه ان
تكون سلاح هيمنه استراتيجي برايك
مثل ما شرحت ذلك فان التوجه العالمي هو
الاعتماد على الذات الاكتفاء الذاتي الذي
يحكم الغذاء ويحكم الامن هو نفسه الذي
ينبغي ان ينطبق على هذا القطاع بحيث يشعر
اي مواطن في دولته بانه غير مقطوع عن
الارض ففي حال كانت الدوله مكتفيه ومعوله
على امكانياتها الذاتيه فحتى قطع العلاقه
معها لن يؤثر بها ولن يقود ذلك اداء
مهامها يتطلب ذلك توفر حد ادنى من البنيه
عبر كابلات النطاق العريض او الاتصالات
الدوليه ما يجعل الدوله في الظروف
المتقلبه مثل اليوم تضمن الارتباط
بالانترنت لجميع مواطنيها